okay everybody I am really excited today
because I have Nina kiri who plays Alma
on the Handmaid's Tale which I just
reviewed I loved it so much and she was
one of my favorite characters so this is
really exciting for me Nina how you
doing today I'm good how are you Steve
excellent so Nina a lot of people don't
know you were born in Serbia and then
now you live in Canada I was curious
what did you move to Canada well in
Serbia in the 90s when I was born there
was a civil war so my family left the
country and moved to Canada I moved to
Vancouver hmm and yeah that's why we
left Wow Wow how younger you and that
when you actually like came into Canada
I was super that I was just one that was
a holy way okay I don't remember but we
spent a lot of time and like we went to
Serbia a lot like in the summer to visit
my grandparents and like yeah so it kind
of got a feel for the country and you
lived in Canada basically for the rest
of your life after that yeah okay and
then I wanted to know - growing up a
Canada when did you know you wanted to
be an actress was there a specific
moment to Germany specific idols that
inspires you um well actually my sister
was in an acting class for like kids
when I was like five or six and I would
go with her and then I was like I want
to go and then I've been doing it and I
really loved it but like you know you
know you're a kid you don't really care
for anything you feel like doing chores
yes I've been doing it since I was
really young but I wasn't until I
started doing a lot of improv in high
school that I was like oh my god like I
remember doing this when I was a kid
this is the best and I went to actually
a film there's a film school in BC where
I'm from and it's called Gulf island
film and television school and it's for
like kids like 13 to 18 and you make
your own short films there and I went
when I was 13 and I was like this is so
cool like we were just making our own
projects
and a lot of my friends who were in the
program
they were like 18 so they were going on
to like college and a lot of them
started going to film school and then
they were like oh Nina do you want to be
in my short film and by that time I was
in high school and so I would just act
in there like weird short films and I
was like I really like this and so I
called yeah so I called this agency and
I was like can I be in your agent they
were like okay and then they saw like
the short films that I did so that's how
I actually like started oh wow that's
that's pretty wild I like that you
called the agency - that that's pretty
cool so I was wondering - when you were
doing these short films did you have a
specific genre you were drawn to like
was a comedy was a drama was it
specifically acting or did you kind of
like directing - or stuff like that
and no at that time I was just acting
because I wasn't I don't think I had the
capacity to like do anything more but in
school it was like comedy because of
improv which is like mostly based off of
short comedic sketches but I don't know
like short films are so weird so so many
of them were like serious I remember a
couple of them were funny but most of
them were like weird or dark or serious
that I ended up doing so I think it
would like comedy at school with like
live theatre but um short films and all
the indie films I do a better or short
films are always like dark so I think I
was both no there wasn't anything I like
liked more yeah I noticed too when I was
looking at your IMDB that you did a
couple of horror movies I think like
three of them recently and did you enjoy
doing har like was that like a challenge
for you how did you feel in that what
kind of role I mean those sounds were
more like I had um just like decided to
start I just graduated from University
and I was like okay like I'm gonna move
to Toronto and I'm just gonna do the
acting thing
so those films were more like an
opportunity for me to play a lead role
like I wasn't necessarily like I want to
do horror but I got cast as like the
lead role and maybe like crazy cool
multi-dimensional characters that I
could play and I was like yes I want to
do this but it wasn't necessarily that
I'm a fan of horror it was that
happened to be in horror genre right but
after doing them I had such a way bigger
respect for horror because you know
they're so expanded horror are the
ultimate fans but they just love it and
they're so supportive and people who
make horror films also are such big fans
before and so it's being around that you
can't help but kind of like like feed
off of the enthusiasm for that oh yeah
so I think I like got that Judiasm for
horror from it not that I'm trying to do
like another million horror films but
for now I'm saturated but like it was
still great to do I think that's awesome
I was wondering - you're currently in
Canada so is there a lot of film work in
Canada because I don't think like from
the US a lot of people even know that
like The Handmaid's Tale for example is
even filmed in Canada because I I didn't
know that and it seems like a lot of
work is going there right now yeah there
actually is I mean Tonto and Vancouver
both have a lot of productions that
shoot up here and I think it's a money
thing because um I think it's like it
cost less up here yeah taxes and also
the Canadian dollar so there actually is
a lot of work up in in Toronto and
Vancouver and there's also like a very
wonderful indie film team in Toronto at
least that I like know of and there's a
lot there's like a good film community
here people are wanting to collaborate
and like do things and I think that's so
awesome
yeah and there's a couple famous film
festivals in Toronto that's really cool
and now have you had thoughts about
moving to the u.s. at all well yeah I do
have artist visa so I can go down to I
can live down there for up to three
years if I wanted to so I do sometimes
go back and forth if I have a certain
meeting or something and I might be like
it depends when I finished filming but
for now like I have my apartment in
Toronto and that's like where I feel is
my home but I'm definitely not opposed
to the idea it's just a issue of like
timing when I when I finish filming and
I might be going down for a couple
months next year to LA you know I'll see
ya I actually I didn't even cost me Oh
yeah I had a couple of meetings there
great very cool okay so going into the
Handmaid's Tale which actually just
watch I was late to the party but it's a
huge role for you to land and it's a
huge TV show to land on what was the
partition process like for that well I
actually like it wasn't a very long
process because my character was
supposed to be only in the first episode
and so the audition was like oh this is
this random girl and I'm like oh this
show I know this because the book is
written by a Canadian author Margaret
Atwood so I had read the book like in
high school it's actually like one of
those books that you have to read in
high school for certain schools oh okay
and so I wasn't this is so cool oh my
god like this literally I just remember
being like this is the epitome of
anything I would ever want to be and and
I didn't even know how big it would be
or anything it was just the way it was
written and like the people that were
working on I'm like this is so cool
but like any audition I'm like I don't
care if I don't get it whatever and then
it was just this audition and then I had
one or two callbacks for it and I met
Reed and one of the callbacks and
luckily I had just read an article about
Reed and how cool she is on this online
publication and luckily I like didn't
realize that that was her like I didn't
when I read like oh you're gonna be
meeting with the director I didn't
really done any merger but oh it's some
like cool woman suite and I didn't read
that it was her name I'm recommending
because I think if I had I would have
been like so much more nervous yeah but
I realized when I came home that that
was her and I was like oh my god so then
I got cast after a couple of auditions
and then even when we were shooting the
first episode I was like oh this is so
cool like we would have random nice
thing that I get to do for like five
days and that's all it's going to be and
then adding realize and then they they
wrote me into more of the episodes so
like every single time I would I would
come on I was so cool I get could be
here for another time and all this and
there's like the end of the season I
like I'm still here
Wow so you said read the book beforehand
and required reading now Alma is also in
the book and I was wondering did almost
character in the book affect your
approach of playing her in the show in
any way or did you like keep just focus
on Alma that's written in the script I
think although was more like I had my
wandering eye on a book okay Oh kept it
in mind mama even wandering - no okay I
kept it in mind that's the expression
but I didn't like what I really liked
about Alma in script was that she is
just so like read like who is this
person who's under this totalitarian
regime has literally like gossiping and
acting like this normal girl in the face
of everything and I just loved that like
I loved that like the first time you see
almost she's like smiling she's like hey
oh my god and they're like at the
stoning and I just found that to be so
awesome especially because I'm like
looking around me and everyone else is
under so much tension and there's so
much tension in the show and they just
really I didn't want to have the book
affect me too much because I don't think
that in the show Gary had not that it's
not affecting Uncle Matt too much but
it's not affecting her in the sense that
she she is under that same tension that
so many characters are under so so that
was why I didn't really focus too much
on her from the book I kind of was
focusing on her as like a contrast to
the show when we were filming it I see
so the interesting thing about Alma is
there's like a lot of mystery
surrounding her I feel and that we know
that she's kind of has connections to
Mayday of the resistance group and I'm
wondering as an actress when you know
this and you're making choices as an
actress are you creating in your head
information about her that we don't know
so you know where to go with that may
anything like are you creating like oh
all my must know this or almost know
that or is like the directors telling
you stuff that the audience doesn't know
so you know what she actually knows or
like
I don't know if you don't saying I have
you yeah um I'm trying to think what I
did when we were doing that I mean kind
of like yeah in a sense we can kind of
it's pretty anybody could use their
imagination to create anything they want
and I think I sort of did during those
episodes but it's so funny because like
at the end of the day you're really just
because you're just like playing off of
people and like playing with people and
you know like Bruce will be there and
I'll be like oh my god like this and
he's like I know I was thinking this for
Alma and I you know you're talking to
people about it and it's such a team
effort that it doesn't even necessarily
have to be you think of something in
your head like maybe you know that day
on set you're talking about it with
someone and that can really help you out
in terms of like how am I going to play
this or like what's going to be in my
head when I play this but for the most
part I didn't do much analysis into it I
was more kind of like feeding off of the
immediate state of you know where am I
who am I talking to and lay you know
what are we talking about and and like I
don't like to go too much into things
sometimes because I'm it's nice to be
able to play off of my immediate
surroundings when I'm on set and just
kind of like work off of that I don't
know maybe that's like the improviser in
me forever oh so you don't do a merger
with your home I do like to think
lighter in that sense because I find
that I can get to cooler places when I'm
more open to like you know feeding on
people I mean so it's it is such like a
dark show obviously and intense and
dreary now on set when you're in a show
like that
do you feel that feeling constantly
because like a lot of these scenes are
like that and just like when you go home
and you're off of work just like snap
out of that kind of reality you're in
yes I see what you're saying and
actually that just that's funny because
in the first season I really didn't feel
that like I never felt it was like but
yes ok and how I watched the first
episode and I was like holy [ __ ] this is
so dark and I just remember being like
oh my god is anybody else - when do we
make because we had this like little
screening before it was like colored or
you know and I was like this is very
dark and and then it isn't until
actually like the second season that I'm
aware of how it's coming off and how
dark it is and we've had a couple of
scenes where I'm just like I had it's
been really hard like wow a couple of
even like that was that that was really
intense and my June you know even our
amazing like background that we have
like there's just some times and you
know someone kind they like freaks out
and it's like oh this is hard
and I'm just like no I know so so there
actually have been a couple of days
where I like even I go home and I'm like
I just need to watch like binge watch
stupid TV and I'm like hang out with my
boys something happy and forget about
Julia yeah exactly
so I was antsy - what was it like
working with big stars like Elisabeth
Moss and hand out
did you have a moment on set we were
like like holy [ __ ] like pinch me I'm
really doing this I'm working with these
big-time actors now like did you feel
like a that kind of like moment at all
oh yeah actually in the first episode
that I shot where I was like oh I'm so
free day like what I didn't realize that
I didn't what I was just so cool yeah
and like I was on I think it was it
wasn't Liz Elisabeth Moss it wasn't
Lizzy it was Alexis because you know I
had I am highly watched madnes and I
knew like what lives in a diamond and
stuff but it was more Alexis Pacific
Alexis is literally on Gilmore Girls I'm
like who doesn't know that show an
Alexis and I was like hey I know like
I'm you know and then they were just so
awesome it was like the first second was
like oh my god I was like know how it is
with people like if everyone's just a
person and you're kind of just like this
is really cool but at the same time
there's something about having to tell
where I just feel like we're all on the
same team it's never felt like oh my god
this person is a big star and like who
am i it's always been like this person a
really good actor and
because of that I feel like I'm doing so
much so much more to work and like so
much better as an actor because of it
I'm even more feels like we're all in it
together as opposed to like I'm working
with these big stars well I even didn't
expect that like I was like so weird I
feel so a part of this and I'm not even
like feeling intimidated or weird I'm
all like even I surprised myself with
that for you also I was gonna say one of
my favorite scenes in the show is when
The Handmaid's are being presented to
the Mexican officials in that ballroom
and the scene to me was shot so
beautiful and you deliver the most
shocking line I thought of the season
and haunting when you said gilead only
has one thing to trade that anyone wants
they want to trade us they trade for
handmaids
I screamed when I watched this scene
because I didn't make that connection I
really thought they were just trading
for like Crocs and [ __ ] but uh when you
when you deliver that and you knew you
had that pay little line did you feel
pressure delivering that did you do that
line and one take like because there's
so many people on set that day I imagine
yeah I don't know I I don't think I just
don't think I remember from that day
yeah I think I just did it like you're
not sure I think it's like in it I think
I did it
actually this is funny because the one
thing I remember from that day was that
because you could see you could like so
we were standing in front of a mirror so
you could kind of see in a shot the
people that were behind that were in
front of our faces so for the entire
time we were shooting that everybody
like Joseph Fiennes like all these
people had to pretend to be playing with
kids oh and it was so funny I was like
oh my god I'm watching these like groan
it's just funny like actors I'm like
watching actor it has to do these like
people like pretending to be playing
with kids but there's no kids and then
that was like one thing from that day
that I remember being like that was
funny that's a play no I I remember yeah
that that line I remember being like oh
my god this is insane like wow and I
think I probably like did it and then
Florida was like wait can you do it so
that like you put emphases on this and I
was like okay cool and then
oh let's do it like this so it wasn't in
any way like different than another
thing that I had said but yeah I
remember being like holy like this is
crazy that this is happening and Alma
knows
oh yeah I guess it was kind of just yeah
like like pretty much any other day and
again I feel so stupid when I'm talking
to you because I'm like all these things
I didn't realize until I'd seen the show
where that crazy yeah at the time you're
just going to work and you're just doing
what you're supposed to be doing and you
don't realize like how it's necessarily
gonna play out to the entire show sure
no you're in that world and then like
all sudden you see it translated as a
show and as a medium and then you're
like wow this is the product right like
that's gotta be a wild feeling so what
won Best Drama series of the Emmys and I
saw pictures you at the red carpet there
was on a surreal experience like being
at that yes okay that was really cool
that was yes I was probably where I was
like oh my god
I can't believe I'm here and that I'm on
this show and yeah I guess that was
probably a moment of like wow I thought
this year was crazy like that was where
it kind of like clicked to me but um so
it's really fun though like I had so
many of my friends although my friends
came down with me just to like do you
like my pump up squad I'm like I don't
always that I work with a lot in in
Vancouver came came down to do my makeup
so it was just nice to have like I don't
know I was more just like a huge
celebration with that whole again we
were just having so much fun so it was
such a good way I felt of like
celebrating that because I just had
people that I like love around me and I
was with Madi from the show and Matt has
become one of my really good friends it
was great and touch a good time yeah you
guys are on set was there a feeling I've
with the whole show or like did people
start saying like I like this show is
gonna be great we're gonna we're gonna
be up for Best Drama like does that ever
conversation ever come up like is there
like a awareness to that I think so like
there are moments or it was like this
show is gonna be the best show ever like
okay I think it was a lot of the time
like crew who would be watching playback
or maybe watching the monitor and they
like oh my god and I'm like County and
they're like this show is going to be
dope and I'm like oh my god
so yeah I think there was kind of like
an excitement there I don't know like I
can't really see for other people I I
definitely was kind of like taking it as
it came just because that was my like
that was kind of where I was at with the
show I wasn't like helping to produce it
or like you know I wasn't seeing all
this footage from the day and and like
seeing what would happen and I kind of
like that whenever I'm acting and things
to just not know coz then Bennet I I
don't think about it too much and I can
just kind of focus on like performing
you know yeah definitely
so speaking of you performing I want to
switch over to I saw on your Instagram
you promoted a Vimeo video you did
called semester abroad anyone could
watch on Vimeo you star in it and you
wrote in it too
do you write a lot and is this something
you want to do more of yeah well
actually with that same crew of people I
just finished filming a web series that
we're going to that were like like I
don't know people can release it in
January and like I like writing I'm more
just like from that I don't know like
from what I was saying improv and stuff
I I just I like things like that and I
like comedy so I actually just it's just
a couple of people that I've worked with
in the industry and then in Toronto that
I like randomly like came across and we
were like oh my god we should write and
we ended up just working so well
together
and I don't know like I would love to
write more in the future like maybe even
something more serious but I think it
was just so much fun and I loved doing
that that like that's why I did it it
was out and he's like I don't even know
if we're gonna whatever we're gonna
release it and we're gonna try and get
it into web festivals much at the same
time like it's just been so amazing like
we shot the last episode this weekend
and we had a bunch of our friends come
out to be extra it was just the best
feeling - it's an amazing feeling right
like put words onto paper and then watch
people like say them and kind of oh yes
so yeah it's like amazing so like it's
like that was one of like that project
ideas my friends was one of the coolest
things I've ever done
like I don't know I can't explain
whenever we're shooting we're like oh my
god is this realize like this is so cool
that's amazing so yeah that's kind of I
don't know what if I'll be writing more
but I I do like love it a lot and I love
even just producing and making those
things happen so hopefully I'll have
more opportunities to do that in the
future and I would love to so
specifically with semester abroad where
do the inspiration for this video come
from
it was just classic like we've all gone
to like we've all done like our
bachelor's degrees and we were we always
like make fun of things and that's
actually one of my friends and we always
joke about like people who are like oh
my god like when I was on exchange and I
too went on exchange to France I'm like
was probably just as douchey about it
and we just thought that was funny and
we were like so it kind of all of the
things that we make fun of are like
situations we have been in ourselves
kind of like you know how everyone right
so we had been we had like medical
people who were like that we were like
oh my gosh and then so we just we drew
the iteration from that and then we kind
of like wrote it together after we had
like the original idea which is normally
how we wrote the entire web series as
well just like we had the core idea
because it had been something that had
happened to us and then and then we kind
of like right from there you know when I
was watching this video semester abroad
I noticed your transition of accents was
incredible and it was making me feel
like I was almost hallucinating because
I was like wait is she speaking
different now and like it was so smooth
and I was wondering do you speak a ton
of languages or like because you in
Canada you've been the u.s. you've been
around it feel like does that kind of
come to that like yeah I do well I seek
Serbian and I seek French but I love
doing accents and my whole dad side of
the family so when we moved to Canada
when I was kid my whole dad side of the
family moved to Australia because
everybody was leaving Serbia and we were
originally supposed to live in Australia
but we couldn't get a visa and then
Canada was just giving them out at the
time so we came to Canada that's the
only reason that we moved
Canada but because of that I had a lot
of family that lived in Australia so
when I was little we actually went to
Australia a lot to see them so I just
like and I always loved loved Australia
like I was always a cleaning lives here
when I'm older and I just I guess
because we spent too much time there the
action was like really easy for me to
like pick up but I I love doing accent
like I just love doing things like that
and yeah you had a really really good
show an accent that maybe I was like
wait she's from Australia I had to like
double-check like now in the video you
mentioned surfing and I noticed you had
a picture on Instagram of something
surfing related I don't remember what it
was exactly
but do you surf like do you have an
obsession of like surfing um no I just
but I have thirst kind of a lot but not
like enough to make me good of it I
don't know I surfed a little bit I'm not
that good is this pot is a pot full of
surfing Canada at all is there anywhere
to go
yeah well where I grew up in Vancouver
um there's a lot of surfing because it's
it's on the west coast and we used to go
to there's a play called Vancouver
Island and there's this play called to
see know on Vancouver Island where you
could surf so that's where I've surfed a
lot and also visiting my family in
Australia I used to surf a lot there
because I would be like bored with like
only family and then my aunt was like do
you want to take surfing and I was like
yeah anything to get so then I searched
a lot actually and then I went to like
Costa Rica and I was like oh my god like
two years ago and I like surfing a lot
and I thought it was cool like
multi-talented I liked it so before I
let you go Nina I have to ask question I
was wondering and I think he kind of
hinted at it but we'll all my be in
season 2 of The Handmaid's Tale yes whoo
I cannot wait that is great news
yeah I really are you guys still filming
a second season it's like everything you
want to know that hat literally even I
was like oh my god everything that you
want to know and that you're like hoping
is gonna happen after you've watched the
first season happens in the second
season and it's incredible I cannot wait
and that is coming out in April on Hulu
have you guys finished filming the
season or is it still kind of in
production no it's still in production
yeah Wow yeah I'm gonna be filming for a
bit of time actually like into the new
year are you are you calling me from
gilead right now are we allowed to be
fine
[Laughter]
I've actually been by this and no no I'm
not I understand my apartments but yeah
we are I was actually shooting this week
though oh well yeah we're still in full
swing yeah so definitely catch Nina and
Handmaid's Tale season 2 in April on
Hulu and then you mentioned your web
series in January where we'll be able to
find that when it releases we're gonna
release it on YouTube and we're gonna
just yeah we're doesn't really say
anything and anywhere I'm sure you'll be
promoting it on our Instagram I'll tweet
about it yeah okay cool yeah I'll give
the treat okay so definitely follow Nina
on Twitter and Instagram check out her
short story videos semester abroad on
Vimeo and thank you so much for joining
me Nina I'd love to have you on again
after season two airs I'd be awesome hey
thank you I was really into a Tottenham
peer yes thank you so much everyone keep
coming back for more celebrity
interviews and please subscribe